[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez un cours d'art à l'école dans
lequel on zappera peinture et des
étoiles mais rien d'autre
donc plutôt que d'apprendre d'eux prend
le temps d'étudier des oeuvres de
picasso van go finir nos domaines si
vous passez la nuit raffiné vous étoiles
comme celle là est ce que ça donne le
goût continuer ce que ça me ferait et
millar dans sa globalité dans la
peinture
je pense qu'à la finance mondiale choses
comme les cours d'art à l'école est une
perte de temps ça fait réaliser à quel
point j'aimais pas la peinture mais ce
que voulait dire plutôt avec ça c'est à
quel point j'aime pas peindre des
étoiles d'accord mais s'en prendre à des
toiles python printemps à regarder sous
tous ses aspects donc d'informer toute
la balle et qu'on est pas notre vision à
l'encens l'immensité de l'espace qui les
entoure
est ce que les résultats ne seraient pas
plus séduisant je pense que c'est là
qu'on peut voir la beauté donc
l'immensité de l'espace dans lesquels on
habite
croyez le ou non c'est peut être ça qui
matent nous enseigner en occident donc
ce qu'on voit à l'école et seulement une
petite partie
cette science là et en conséquence on
peut avoir beaucoup de difficultés a
donc avant la pertinence l'aboutissement
de ce qu'on étudie bon certains
pourraient en tirer une conclusion du
jarret les cours de maths à l'école est
une perte de temps j'ai vraiment pris
mes soeurs et moi je vais vous répondre
et dont on sent qu'il entre vraiment on
a agi mon analogie donc on sent que tu
as qui vous n'êtes pas encore à
l'étranger l'étape de peindre les sports
sont nantis mais que vos talents de
peintre sur se contenter jusqu'à
maintenant tout de même des étoiles donc
mon but aujourd'hui ça va être donc de
vous montrer de vous guider à travers
cet espace-là de cette science le qu'il
ya plus présente dans notre société sans
qu'on réalise pour autant et pour les
sceptiques et ou pour ceux qui ont pas
fait le match depuis longtemps je pense
pas qu'on ait vraiment besoin d'être
mathématicien pour pouvoir bénéficier
donc de cette science donc en ce qui me
concerne je suis ici en médecine donc je
suis pas la prétention d'être à la
hauteur le mathématicien mais ça empêche
peut donc des passionnés par ces
domaines le qui selon moi permet
vraiment comprendre les phénomènes qui
nous entoure
c'est pour vous dire que la science dont
je parle
cette science qui étudie les collections
et nombre et lit partout et elle permet
d'abord de satisfaire à la fois donc un
désir plus mondial la curiosité mais
aussi de répondre à la question vraiment
fascinante gens recommencent que le flux
sanguin fonctionne ou de répondre à des
questions existentielles du genre en
france qu'est mon compte de banque qui
est toujours libre
ok alors qu'un exemple donc augmente nos
étoiles quand j'étais petit je me suis
toujours posé une question ça va c'est
trop comment une étoile est bon puisque
je n'ai pas de réponse mais s'est décidé
à trouver par mois - et ceci avant de
savoir actuellement si netoyer spirit
c'est en trois dimensions et non pas en
forme d'étoilé de mer avec des pointes
comme celle là qui donc sinon comment
une étoile comme celle là autrement dit
c'est quoi son r si je pense qu'ils
émettront sa largeur et sa longueur sont
de 2 m donc on a tous fait ensemble à
l'école comment calculer l'art de figure
à la de formule n'est ce pas donc pour
un client on va les faire passer à
hauteur et ardu encore et on peut faire
courir aux côtés pour un disque on va
les faire pif à le rayon au carré bien
d'autres formules de cela mais c'est là
qu'on sorte à notre première qui est
existentiel à savoir ya pas de formules
pour une étoile
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait futur non
c'est vrai je vais plutôt vous invitiez
a essayé de pratiquer un raisonnement
qui frappe au match dans lequel fut
prendre ce que vous savez déjà et
l'appliquer à la nouvelle situation
donc nos têtes aux lessives qu'est ce
qu'on peut voir des quatre pointes ville
comptait avant dis pas ce que je viens
de dire
côté a bondi en france et un certain
cercle plein
c'est un disque on fait pareil jusqu'ici
oui non peut-être
donc j'appelle la question vous voir un
disque des disques sur l'image oui donc
comment je vais voir on est positionnant
comme ça qu'est ce que je vais faire
tout simplement coupé mon étoile en
quatre morceaux identique et puis après
il suffit de placer ou quatre coins
façon symétrique et on obtient cette
figure là et là tout ce qui me reste à
faire s'est soustrait à la halle du
disque al-askari
et on obtient vous savez maintenant
comment calculer l'air d'une étoile mike
donc dans ce problème là sa demande ait
aussi un peu de créativité
donc autant développe deux côtés de
raisonnement logique de réflexion
mathématique a aussi dit m en même temps
à coude et créatif qui vraiment cool et
l'exemple ici c'était pour montrer que
souvent les matches nous permettre de
comprendre les choses de façon
différente et en fait ça nous donne
souvent une meilleure compréhension des
choses
donc c'est cool d'avoir une bonne
compréhension mais ce qu'ali mathlouthi
nous aider à avoir rendu leur décision
donc bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui à télé
québec
vous courez la chance de gagner une
voiture ou des gentils animaux ok voici
comment ça marche en fait là la patte
sur le mouton et le cochon sont répartis
alarmant derrière trois portes
ça serait si une et vous repartez avec
ce que derrière mais attention vous
voyez que nous couvrir qu'une seule
porte laquelle allez vous choisir on est
avec un vote à main levée d'accord tous
ceux qui veulent la porter et on every
apporte du rapport 3 la majorité semble
ait la porte numéro 3 mais c'est une
telle majorité
mais bon alors son qui vous prenez la
porte numéro 3 mettant à mon tour donc
ans les deux potes qui reste mois est
animateur et sachant où se trouve la
voiture
je leur renouvelle une mise en la numéro
2 qui contient un cochon et maintenant
mesdames et messieurs je vous offre une
opportunité donc d innover gardez votre
choix
la porte numéro 3 ou plutôt changer pour
la porte numéro un
donc tous ceux qui veulent gagner sur
initial on aimerait et tous ceux qui
veulent qu'on change de porte
ok bon cette fois ci le peuple a parlé
on va garder la porte quand on voit ce
qu'il se sépare donc la porte numéro 3
ok alors 11 ouvrir les portes et vous
gagnez le mouton bon c'est pas truqué le
poignet du à fait
bref vous aurez sûrement quel choix
était lui entre changy de porte ou
conservés en importe dans cette
situation là je pense qu'effectivement
les jugements semblent aussi bon
l'enclos d'antenne probabilité ans donc
on a une voiture on animal de le porte
50/50 promet alors bien cognitif
l'attend avec moi qui essaient de
pervertir changer de peau
au nom des enfants on en reste à faire
non plus tordus ici mais pour éviter
toute source de bié une solution simple
et celle exprimée la situation d'un
point de vue mathématique
en fait il existe deux scénarios
possibles donc dans le premier scénario
de belles choses et pas n'importe qui
contient la voiture puis moi j'en ouvre
une autre et j'entends cela vous devez
conserver cette porte là pour pouvoir la
gagner
cet accord est ce scénario la griffe une
fois sur trois comme une valeur et 3
portes
mais non dans le deuxième scénario vous
avez choisi au départ une porte qu'on
sait pas la voiture dans une ancienne
cochons moutons et moi un jour ou
l'autre particulier l'autre animal et
l'ambiance que la france vous êtes
taggart il faut changer de porte donc
changer de choix pour gagner la voiture
et c'est deuxième scénario arrive tu le
fasses urtois com
en e2 animaux parmi les trois portes et
donc on a là deux tiers des chances de
gagner la batture si on change de porte
il se marre est allé chance si on
conserve notre choix initial
je pense une façon d'illustrer sa serait
donc sous la forme d'un arbre de
probabilité donc si on regarde ici la
branche dans au rap au centre et les
scénarios or et les deux branches du spa
le scénario du et tout ce qu'on a à
faire maintenant c'est multiplier les
possibilités sur chaque planche donc sur
chaque chemin
de gauche à droite pour obtenir la
probabilité total que l'événement est
boostée par la branche se réalise
ici on fait la somme sur la tis yonne
les probabilités total on sent quand
encore une fois qu' on aurait deux tiers
des chances de gagner la voiture si on
change de portes et seulement un tiers
si on conserve la même porte donc alors
que vos éditions vous emporter à croire
peut-être le contraire
28 matchs ont permis de prendre une
décision éclairée ici donc la morale de
l'histoire c'est vraiment climat'' peut
nous aider à prendre de meilleures
décisions
bon je parle de morale c'est en train de
devenir un peu philosophique mon affaire
vous savez autrefois les maths et la
philo ne faisait qu'un donc beaucoup de
grands mathématiciens donc je pense à
des gens comme m
blaise pascal et des cartes ou même
livni ce qui est créateur dont quelque
10 ans l intégrale lions ont été ou sont
devenus éventuellement des philosophes
je pense que c'est du chant qui se
complémentent parce que les mâles
peuvent nouer mentionnant avait des
réponses ou des résultats qui sont un
peu perturbant déstabilisant voire
effrayant il serait qu'on va se tourner
vers la philo donc pour donner une
justification une explication à ces
réponses le comme par exemple si je vous
dis tout mouvement est impossible dans
la foule parce que je bouge en ce moment
mais pourtant c'est ce que nous venons
d'y aller un philosophe
mathématicien grec a réussi à trouver
grâce à une course opposant la famille
achille contre une tortue donc la
situation se déroule comme à celle étant
un homme humble et justes et gentil qui
accorde une longueur d'avancé à la
torsion disons 10 mètres et donc la
tortue commence à courir à couvrir et
lorsqu'elle atteint le petit m atch il
donc commence lui aussi à courir et
parcourt rapidement les 10 mètres qui le
séparent la tortue mais vous êtes encore
que pendant ce temps là la torture dans
l'ancien par m donc il reste donc à fil
en 11e mètres à parcourir avant de
rattraper la tortue et pendant le cacher
le parcours aux makes la torsion au
comptant ne mentionnons donc peut-être
un corps de m ok mais là achille il
devra attraper un tortueux en parcourant
cette année car de m et pendant qu'ils
étaient seuls la tortue a encore autant
d'avancé un peu mais est aussi petit ou
un film à distance soit l on sent qu'on
cache et le poids j'ai ramé rattraper la
tortue parce qu'à chaque fois qui couvre
la distance sépare la tortue mais la
tortue le temps d'avancer un peu plus et
par conséquent un chiffre jamais
s'attarder l'attention bon vous allez me
dire que ma situation est totalement
absurde parce qu'il est évidemment si on
fait le test dans la vraie vie on se
rend compte que coureur olympique au
marché le boîtier part si facilement la
tortue mais pourtant le poids du
mathématiques ça semble indiquer le
contraire
donc prenons la situation mais je
simplifie encore plus ils ont connu une
pièce que je vais pas courir de gauche à
droite puis la pièce c'est un acte donc
pour commencer il va parcourir la
première moitié et il reste l'autre
moitié à parcourir 50
mais là c'est moi si tu es deuxième
moitié là avant de parcourir au complet
je tapote parcourir sa moitié donc
encore ok donc ces faits restent
interdits car à parcourir mais ce
dernier quart là avant de parcourir au
complet et à parcourir sa moitié donc
8ème il reste dix huitième
mais pour me rendre jusqu'au bout du
temps à 8e avant ça je dois pas que sa
moitié donc un 16e et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à l'infini
donc peu importe la distance qui nous
reste à parcourir en fait elle sera
toujours utilisée à une infinité moitié
ce qu'il en soit et finalement je peux
pas me rendre à côté de la pièce à
l'autre côté en fait en accélérant tout
mouvement est possible sachant qu'avant
de faire un mouvement ben jaffar la
moitié du mouvement mais en fait elle a
menti je dois refaire la mousse et la
moitié et ainsi de suite
donc comment expliquer ce paradoxe là
qui sont si convaincants si je vous dis
que la preuve se trouve devant vous car
dont les causes sont connues ici
d'accord en fait cette affirmation est
finie
cet accord donc une addition est fini de
nombre comme 2100 car sa 8ème 16ème
jusqu'à nice ok la clé ici en fait c'est
qu'une sommation infinie de nombre peut
aboutir à un résultat fini qu'ils ont je
répète on peut être si une ligne car
c'est infini nombre et aboutir à quelque
chose de fini comme un goût de 50000 peu
importe c'est un an notre cas je pense
que la meilleure façon de vous le pouvez
c'est l'illustré bon prenons même
situation
mais cette fois-ci chaque nombre
représente 1 er et ont donc tracer des
rectangles et décors ils correspondent à
la de chaque nombre ils vous voyez que
même s'ils ont une quantité infinie le
rectangle italie s'ils ont ils en
boivent l'eau de façon symétrique
ça va faire au total un corps et
oculaires qui finit une heure d'un mètre
carré ici suite à la récente ce calcul
un fils mal que les mathématiciens ont
pu résulter ce hardox le jeune homme
présentait en fait ça quand on a ici
c'est ce qu'on appelle syrie
géométriques une scierie qui peut être
convergents c'est à dire qui va aboutir
à un résultat fini et il souhaite une
formule pour calculer la convergence ou
la divergence d'une scierie géométriques
formule qui enseigne aujourd'hui dans
tous les cégeps québec et partout à
travers le monde dont gérard meys avant
106 termes scientifiques mathématiques
mais en fait vous comprenez que c'est
juste
mots qu'on a posé pour décrire le
principe de sommation qui va nous
expliquer principe que vous commencez
sûrement à comprendre mais et non lui ya
pas eu de sa science tactique a été
arrêté par le tyran pour cause cette
trahison et qui auraient été exécutés
on demand tué avant sa mort directe
ranchi sa propre langue avec sita et le
rec cracher sur le terrain pour se
venger mais bon à ce que la langue s'est
rendu jusqu'aux tirs au but seulement la
moitié de la moitié on sera jamais a
commis deux touchés ici c'est une
planche du mat
il me permet de travailler avec
infiniment petit grâce au calcul
différentiel est dans notre code
infiniment grand car ce calcul intégral
donc si des facilement fascinant des
matches n'ont pas pu toucher à ça et
donc espèce de vertige qu'on ressent à
jongler que les finis l'astuce de
lancement comme de comprendre une
situation qui dépasse les limites
physiques de notre corps je pense que
c'est cette les maths peuvent apporter
donc pour terminer s'agit vraiment donc
d'un vaste champ de connaissances dans
lequel on peut voyager à travers des
mondes fascinants sans même avoir besoin
de lever le petit doigt
donc tout se passe vraiment là dedans
bon je les informe sans cela mais
comprenez libye donc aujourd'hui on a
parlé un peu de géométrie de
probabilités de calcul financière
intégrale mais il faut savoir aussi que
le monde et matt est loin de s'arrêter
le donc au niveau des mâtures on prépare
les de télémétrie damien théorie des
ensembles et on peut aussi appliquer ça
pour faire des statistiques de
l'économie des maths appliquées à la
physique la chimie la bio donc c'est
vrai une science qui regroupe beaucoup
de domaines donc connect grand couteau
mais dans l'ensemble et c'est ce qu'il
en soit vraiment cool bon look blanc
soldes tout d'un coup comme ça ça peut
sembler un peu peut-être gros ou même
ambitieux vous savez je suis un gros fan
de musique qui joue coupe beaucoup de
piano et jules c'est la chance
d'enseigner à cliquer s'élève donc dans
mon temps libre
mais ce que tous mes élèves aspire à
devenir pianiste de concert ans parce
qu'à dix heures et 10 heures chaque jour
non c'est sûr mais on en reprenant les
bases piano comme le rythme linotte cela
permet de jouer beaucoup de pièces donc
ça fait pas d'eux le mécanisme au monde
certes mais ça permet d'enrichir leur
vie et ça apporte beaucoup de plaisir
donc dans le même ordre d'idées je pense
pas qu'il faudrait créer des maths pour
a précisé que cette discipline peut nous
apporter
donc il suffit d'avoir l'esprit ouvert
et de consacrer du temps et la passion
donc vous invite donc à entrer dans ce
monde là en sachant que ses portes sont
grandes ouvertes et que peu importe ce
que vous allez trouver à l'intérieur ça
vous allait ressortir avec une vision
renouvelée du monde et qui sait
peut-être une nouvelle passion merci
[Applaudissements]